we have two very special guests joining
the desk ross i'm so excited i love
these two we were lucky enough to see
them on zoom last year in our very first
year of this show these are original
gangsters i know we said hopefully
hopefully we'll be able to see you here
in the studio soon well guess what the
dream is happening and it's real it's
wwe all-star beauty entrepreneurs and
the co-hosts of the bella podcast they
share open and honest conversations
about motherhood and relationship oh
here's a listen
what is it when you go wine tasting
everything is good everything tastes
good and then you buy all these bottles
and you come home and then you pop it
open you're like
what is this it's because you and i said
they let it breathe all day long
i can't believe it please welcome back
to the show
thank you for having us i like that you
called us the
yeah yeah ogs
she's here now you kindly came on and
graced us with your presence oh thank
you and super pregnant weren't we stupid
yeah yeah
that's right that's right yeah
we've loved watching you guys over the
years together oh thank you it's been an
incredible journey i mean since the womb
since we've entered this world
we've had a blast but but just like also
being business partners and growing and
being entrepreneurs and what we've done
as women and breaking barriers in the
wwe like we've just been so blessed and
i think as women and what we've done
it's because we have each other so we
were there to lift each other up when it
was tough it's like my husband yeah it's
like a marriage it is like a marriage i
feel bad for her
it's true they'll never have with you
what you have with each other yeah and
they know that
and that's just wonderful yeah i
understand it right and now you're you
you've been you know wwe beauty moguls
and now with the podcast congratulations
thank you people are i love the e-show
too i love you
i always watch the show but what's so
interesting you do on your podcast is i
love you have the guests bring something
with them each episode can you tell us
about that yes so we wanted guests to
start bringing their favorite quote or
something that means something to them
because we love ending the podcast with
something that's inspiring something
that our listeners can take away and be
like you know i needed that today and
it's also kind of cool because we're
always like our guests when they tell
you their quote you're kind of like
that's who you are as a person and they
always give some like intimate story to
that or you know why this motivates them
why this drives them and so it's it's
you see a different side of people when
they come on all right do you guys want
to do some headlines with us yes all
right rossi take it away okay well first
first we have a big wedding debate to
settle the independent reports a groom
asked if he was a jerk for kicking his
own brother-in-law out of his wedding
but first you have to hear why he did it
because in addition to making rude
comments about the wedding at the
wedding uh during the ceremony itself
the brother-in-law decided to start
handing out invitations for his own
upcoming wedding yeah okay so he said
you're outta here what do you all think
because there was a big debate online do
you think this crossed the line or was
the groom a jerk so i'll say
definitely rude but i think it's a
little harsh to kick your brother-in-law
out of the wedding what okay i'd be like
au revoir yeah
like really what
if you started to see my wedding at my
wedding and then handing invitations out
of like brie pack your bags go to your
hotel room i'll catch you tomorrow for
sure i have to say i'm with nikki on the
stream
i mean what a
jerk move yeah this guy can just take a
big fat hike
[Applause]
i'm planning my wedding right now and
i'll tell you if you come to my wedding
and diss it to my face at least have the
decency to talk about me behind my back
okay
like a normal human being you are out of
my wedding out of here
will you take our next headline please
ladies oh yes we'd love to
all right so next we got a workout
that's trending that we absolutely love
real simple reports if you want to get
some good cardio in try
jumping rope
it gets the blood pumping quick and
fitness pro say if you go back to the
activities you love as a kid it can
increase your enjoyment in working out
as an adult yes it works on so many
muscle groups at once it hits calves
core arms shoulders upper back ross and
drew want to try it with us um oh wait a
minute is it true that you guys do this
we do it with our trainer it's a good
warm-up so
you can burn so many calories jumping up
and have a lot of fun and it can make
you smile really quick okay well just
ladies
you know when we're kids and we jump
rope yeah why is it so different now
start to fall to the ground and now we
have to really lift them up we got jump
ropes right here you want to try come
over here
come over here
and pull up my pants be careful on these
heels yeah this is a bad idea wow all
right
you know how i feel about this okay any
tips high and fast because sometimes
slow you trip but you came fast
there we go oh smart oh yeah yeah good
cute
[Applause]
i love it
do you do that on purpose or is that a
total accident that is a total
i was like oh well here we go okay okay
i feel like you could kind of though do
the step first before the two yeah
yeah you're right the step okay ready
you know like
yeah there you go oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's not easy but it's doable
ria and nikki bella pre nicki i love you
guys so much thank you so much
thank you nicki and greek at the bellas
podcast on sirius xm stitcher and we'll
be right back
[Music]